hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my 10 things you might have missed in
Game of Thrones season 7 episode 2 if
you ever watched episode 2 yet then
you're going to want to stop watching
this video now because it does contain
spoilers for the episode check out some
of my other Game of Thrones videos
though if you're leaving and for those
of you who stayed there are quite a few
callbacks to earlier episodes here we
noticed some of these in the first
episode but there were just a ton here
so I have a feeling we're going to be
seeing more of this stuff as the season
goes on that they are moving towards the
end so let's jump into it the first one
was a little bit obvious especially if
you just recently been through the Camus
1 series maybe but in case you did miss
it John is not the first member of the
family to choke out Littlefinger of
course we saw this scene where he gets
angry about Sansa
and what Petyr Baelish says there and he
chokes him down there in the crypts in
front of Ned statute well Ned himself
had way back in season 1 episode 3 when
he found out that Littlefinger had been
hiding Catelyn in one of his brothels
now of course Ned isn't actually John's
father we know that now but he still the
man who raised him and we see that he's
passed on the tendency to choke out
weasels to John either way it's also
worth noting here that we found out that
Littlefinger is the one who brought home
Ned bones out of respect for cat these
bones had been a mystery so it's nice to
know that they've been brought back and
he's been laid to rest with all of this
dark ancestors the second thing you
might have missed is the thing that Arya
said - Nymeria is a callback to
something that she said to her father
and season 1 I talked about the meaning
of what she said in my recap and review
for this episode but if what she
actually said and what the description
is sounds a little familiar it's because
it's referencing something that Arya has
said whenever Ned was talking to her
back in season 1 he was saying that bran
would grow up and be a lord of a castle
and Arya asked if she could be a lord -
and what he said was you'll marry a high
Lord and we'll
castle and your son's shall be knights
and princes and Lords REO responds no
that's not me so you know she's kind of
referencing herself whenever she tells
Nymeria it's not you
the third thing you might have missed
was a little call back from Daenerys
when she responds to Melisandre
Melisandre says as Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch he allowed the wildlings
south of the wall to protect them from
great danger as king in the north he has
United those wildlings with the northern
houses so together they may face their
common enemy so you know she's saying
that jon is really quite an impressive
leader and Daenerys responds he sounds
like quite a man now back in season five
Samwell was reading a letter to maester
aemon that said things about the nurse
herself had said that and though
Daenerys Targaryen maintains her grip on
slavers Bay forces rise against her from
within and without she refuses to leave
until the freedom of the former slaves
is secure and then Sam says to Amon she
sounds like quite a woman so it's pretty
much the same thing just the roles are
reversed here fourth thing you might
have missed another callback was that
Queen of Ashes comment that tyrion said
you know he mentioned that if he
attacked as tens of thousand people
would be burned and she'd be known as
the queen of ashes well back in season 3
episode 4 Varys is talking to Olenna
Tyrell and talking about how treacherous
Littlefinger really is and what he says
is that he would see this country burn
if he could be king of the ashes so
there's a little callback there the
first thing you might have missed was
when Tyrion sent his message from
Dragonstone up to Winterfell to John
Snow John pointed out that there was
something in it that made him know that
it was definitely Tyrion you remember
Tyrion and Jon met outside the
celebration way back in the first
episode of the series and John asked him
after he gets angry what would you know
about being a bastard
and hearing replies all dwarves are
bastards in their father's eyes
so John pointed out that that's how he
knew Tyrion really wrote the letter
because that was a conversation they had
but you might not have realized that it
happened way back in the very first
episode in season one the sixth thing
that you might have missed was the
reasoning behind why Sam wants to cure
toros greyscale as you may think these
two guys have never met each other but
Sam obvious knew his father who was Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch when Sam
arrived at the wall so this is a direct
call back to George's father Jorah
Mormont in Episode two of season three
Samwell would have died like literally
died after the battle with the walkers
at the White Walkers at the fist of the
first men if it wasn't for Jorah Mormont
as the brothers are walking he falls to
his knees
remember the steam probably now he
basically gives up he doesn't want to go
on he says they know that the brothers
left him but that door comes back and he
comes over and he delivers the line to
Sam well he says Tarly I forbid you to
die and then the other brothers are kind
of being dick wads or whatever so he
tasks Rast to make sure that fan gets
back alive or else wrathful either
so basically threatens him and in doing
that he saved Sam's life so now Sam
wants to save Joris the seventh thing
you might have missed and this is
another thing I talked about in my last
video but bending the knee is not
something that's likely going to happen
given the history of the king in the
north
now if you're looking at this just from
a character perspective of who Jon Snow
is you might say well maybe he'll be
reasonable about this but it's really
not just his decision I mean there's a
long line of kings here and the people
in the north are people of tradition
right so literally for thousands of
years House Stark has ruled the north
and never bended the knee to anyone now
this goes all the way back like for
contact the stark house is ancient right
they were founded by brand-new builder
who built the wall and that went up
8,000 years ago so it's not like they're
just a new
they have the everything right there
direct descendants of the first men and
there was no time in all of that history
until Aegon and his conquest came
through that they bent the knee they
just always bent like you know the
you've heard of the kings of winter
which some of them called themselves and
the ones that are down in the crypts
right so 8,000 years they never bent the
knee to anyone during the conquest when
Aegon came through towards dark been
Tuni and that earned him the title the
king who knelt like that's what he's
remembered as is his healing to Aegon
and that was in a situation where he was
outnumbered in men like a goes army was
bigger plus they had like three
full-grown dragons and riders and they
had just wiped out the combined forces
of the Riverland so these were extreme
situations and you might say to yourself
well Daenerys has three dragons and oh
yeah it's you know it's after Ned was
taken prisoner by Joffrey for trees and
Rob refused to bend the knee and he
became the king in the north
right and John's feelings or thoughts
aside it's just not something that you
do you know and so it's very unlikely
that John would bend the knee after
what's happened definitely not to Cersei
but even to Daenerys because there is no
immediate threat at this point
what's even more likely is that his
bannermen would accept that like it was
just everything would just fall apart
like he could just explain that to
Daenerys like I'm not bending the knee
because then no one's gonna listen to me
you know I mean and it would be
basically an empty gesture the eighth
thing you might have missed was in the
scene is a lot going on when you're on
has Yara and Theon is kind of having his
breakdown based on his past abuse at the
hands of Ramsay you might have missed
the fact that Euron's crew was walking
around cutting out the tongues of the
survivors from the other side now you
know that his ship is called the silence
and the reason it's called that is is
because he cuts out the tongues of at
least in the books he cuts out all the
tongues of his crew and there's a whole
story that goes into that you can watch
my ear on
character profile video if you want I
will go into all of it now but yeah they
were taking their tongues out right then
so I was pretty interesting called back
to the books if nothing else the nice
thing you might have missed was Jorah
was writing his letter to Daenerys as he
was there basically getting ready to end
his life that's not a terribly big
surprise since he sent you know he was
sent by her to get healed but if you do
then you can pretty much read most of
the letter and it reads Khaleesi
I went to the Citadel in the last hope
that the maesters could treat me as you
ordered even with all and then you can't
read a little bit there it says I am
beyond any cure out the grave I have had
a longer life than I deserved and I only
wish I could have lived to see the world
you're going to build standing by your
side I have loved you since the moment I
met you if there's and there's another
part you can't see and it's sign Jorah
so yeah that's that's a touching thing
to pick up on I guess like I said it's
not a real big surprise that he would
write a letter to her whenever he was
doing that so he doesn't have much
family yeah that's what it says and the
tenth thing you might have missed was
Sam was holding books a Bros was
stacking them up they're not exactly
sure if it was for Sam to read or if
this was for a broses own studies but
one of the books you can see is called
and history of the House Lannister
and I'm not just an idiot that's what it
actually says on there so it's a little
bit messed up grammatically but he's
looking at that history of House
Lannister is it important it might be so
let me know what you guys think I have a
couple other Game of Thrones videos I
want to put out this week so make sure
you check back please like this one
please subscribe to my channel as I put
them out of full schedule of Game of
Thrones videos now the seasons been full
swing on top of all the other stuff I do
please leave me comment about these and
other things that you saw that I might
have missed follow me on Twitter and
like my facebook page and my Instagram
account
and thanks for watching
you soon